Transcriber: Nawal Sharabati
المدقّق: Manal Abed Al Rahman
مساء الخير.
في عام 2020، عندما حصلت
جائحة كورونا المعروفة بكوفيد-19،
حصلت كارثة بشرية على مستوى العالم.
ليس كارثة بشرية فقط، ولكن كارثة اقتصادية.
فشركات كثيرة جدًا خرجت من السوق،
وشركات كثيرة جدًا غيّرت من نشاطاتها،
وشركات كثيرة سرّحت أكثر
من 50 إلى 60% من موظفيها.
قد تغيّر شكل المِهن في العالم كله؛
من موظف يرتدي بدلة ويحمل حقيبة،
تحول إلى موظف يرتدي نصف بدلة
وبنطال بيجاما ويعمل عبر برنامج زووم.
في هذا الوقت، حصل انتعاش
غريب جدًا في سوق موازٍ.
أجرى الموقع الإلكتروني  إنفستوبيديا
(Investopedia)  إحصائية
عن الدولة الأكثر استقرارًا
في هذا الوقت اقتصاديًا.
وطبعًا، كانت الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية.
تعالوا نقفز قفزةً نحو اقتصاد أمريكا،
وجدوا حقائق غريبة جدًا؛
يعتمد %5 من اقتصاد أمريكا
على العمل الحر المستقل،
أحد أكبر منصات العمل الحر في العالم كله،
أجرت إحصائية عام 2020 وهي سنة كوفيد-19.
ووجدت أن 75 مليون أمريكي
كسبوا واحد تريليون دولار في سنة
كان فيه اقتصاد العالم كله يتدهور.
في الحقيقة، بدأت الشركات
تدرس ذلك على المستوى الاقتصادي،
ووجدت أنه أكثر توفيرًا للشركة؛
فبدلًا من أن يأخذ الموظف حيزًا في الشركة،
وتضطر أن تدفع له تعويضًا عن المواصلات،
وتضطر إلى إعطائه راتبًا ثابتًا كل شهر
بغض النظر عن الإنتاج،
فتوصلت إلى قرار الذهاب إلى العمل الحر.
قالت مجلة فوربس في توقعاتها لعام 2023،
أن نسبة التلزيم الخارجي
أو إنتاج الشركات من خارجها
ستكون 73%.
ومن المتوقع طبعًا أنه سيزداد
بشكل كبير في السنوات القادمة.
تقول الأرقام أن اقتصاد العالم الآن
سيتحرك نحو الأعمال الحرة.
على مستوى الأفراد، وفي عام 2020 أيضًا،
أجرت أحد منصات العمل الحر دراسة لطيفة جدًا
اسمها دراسة الاستقالة الهائلة.
سألت الناس إن كانوا يرغبون في الاستقالة.
الغريب أن 10 مليون أمريكي
قالوا أنهم يرغبون في الاستقالة.
والأغرب أن 53% منهم قالوا أنهم يرغبون
في الاستقالة للقيام بالعمل الحر بأنفسهم.
مع أن الشيء الشهير عن العمل الحر
أنه أقل استقرارًا من الناحية المادية.
وطرحوا سؤالًا آخر على الناس،
لماذا يرغبون العمل الحر بأنفسهم؟
كانت أعلى إجابتين:
السبب الأول، كسب المزيد من المال،
ويعد هذا منطقيًا.
وكان السبب الثاني لاكتشاف  المزيد
من اختيارات العمل أي رؤية  مهن أخرى.
الغريب والصادم في هذه الدراسة
أنهم وجدوا أن هذا هو اختيار الأشخاص
الذين كانت تتراوح أعمارهم ما بين
أواخر العشرينات ومنتصف الثلاثينيات.
الغريب أنه في هذا السن، من المفروض
أن نكون قد تخرجنا من الكلية،
وتقدمنا في مجال الوظيفة،
وبدأنا  نحصل على ترقية.
لماذا يقرر أي شخص
في هذا العُمر أن يغير مهنته؟
في دراسة موازية قام بها، وفي نفس السنة،
المركز الوطني للابتكار التكنولوجي تقول:
هل كان الإنسان عندما عمل عن بُعد
وفي أعمال حرة أكثر استقرارًا وأكثر سعادة؟
كانت أيضًا النتائج صادمة.
زادت الروابط الأسرية في سنة الكورونا،
وزاد الاستقرار والرضا الوظيفي
في سنة الكورونا.
بل وجدوا أن العنف الأسري
قلّ بنسبة 8.7% في أمريكا.
الحقيقة أن كل هذه الأرقام سواء كانت
على المستوى النفسي أو على المستوى المهني،
جعلتني أحسُ بأنني محظوظة جدًا.
أنا تخرجت من كلية الطب البشري في عام 2009،
وهي كلية يحلم بها الكثير من الناس.
قضيتُ سنة الامتياز، كما قضيتُ سنة ونصف
في مهنة الطب النفسي،
ومن ثم قدمت استقالتي في وزارة الصحة.
وقررتُ أعمل في مجال العمل الحر،
في فترة لم يكن العمل الحر مشهورًا كثيرًا.
فعملتُ في مجال أحبه كثيرًا
وهو الترجمة الطبية،
التي جمعت بين الشيء
الذي أحب القيام به ودراستي.
في الحقيقة، كان الدخل الذي حصلتُ عليه
من العمل الحر المستقل
يعادل فعليًا أربعين ضعفًا من الدخل
الذي كنت سأحصل عليه من مهنتي الأصلية.
بحلول سنة 2017، أسست أول عمل خاص بي.
وحاليًا في 2023، وأنا في سن 37 عامًا،
أنا مستثمر ملائكي (Angel investor) لمشاريع
ستطرح في الخليج هذه السنة.
(تصفيق)
في الحقيقة، ليست هذه التجربة الإنسانية
التي أتحدث عنها تجربة فريدة من نوعها.
عندما بدأت أتعامل مع العديد
من رود الأعمال في الفترة الأخيرة،
وجدتُ أن معظمهم خريجي طب وصيدلة،
وهندسة، وكليات قمة؛
كليات يحلم بها الكثير من الناس.
ولكن الحقيقة...
لم يعيشوا أسلوب حياة أو حياة مهنية
كان سيفرضها عليهم المجتمع،
لكن قرروا بناءً على الأرقام
والدراسة والاقتصاد
أن يبحثوا عن شغفهم ويتبعوه.
أعرف أن كثيرًا منكم يقول الآن،
كيف لي القيام بذلك؟
في أحد نظريات مثلث الثراء
التي تقول  لك كيف تكون ثريًا،
هو أن يكون عندك مهارة واحدة تقوم
بتسيلها (monetization)  وتحويلها إلى مال.
حسنًا، كيف سأعرف مهارتي؟
أو خطوة هي اكتشاف الذات.
اكتشاف الذات بمعنى أكتشف ماذا أحب،
وإلى أي شيء أميل وما الشيء الذي أعرف عمله.
نحن الآن نتحول إلى عالم مهاري،
فلن تسألك الشركات الآن
من أي كلية تخرجت؟ وما هي خبرتك؟
لكن ستسألك الشركات ما الذي تعرف عمله؟
أتمنى اليوم أن تكون محادثي الصغيرة
دعوة للتفكيرة مرة أخرى.
شكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)